foreign
so it's been a hot minute since there
was a really big camera change here at
MKBHD Studios whatever you want to call
it like this may be the longest I've
ever used a single camera but that's
mostly because these cameras are
incredible and there's almost no way I
could need more camera for YouTube but
also when you start getting around this
type of Cinema Camera a lot of them are
very specialized so when you get past
the mirrorless cameras and dslrs into
the realm of dedicated video cameras and
Cinema cameras a lot of these cameras
are designed to be used by a crew of
several people at once sometimes it's a
big crew sometimes it's a small crew
maybe two or three but that's different
from a one-person camera and as a
YouTuber as a Creator whatever you want
to call it I need a one-person operation
to be possible so I really started
getting into these RED cameras a couple
years ago mainly for the world class
image quality but also because I could
set them up to shoot by myself you just
start with the brain and then I'd
collected the perfect set of accessories
around it to shoot the way I like to and
then the rest of the workflow from there
was pretty simple and that style of
modular camera was called dsmc2 it's
been amazing this this new one is called
dsmc3
and it's pretty intense so red actually
has this sort of tick tock cycle where
they upgrade the sensors inside the
cameras that they design and then also
the camera body itself but not at the
same time so this camera body has the
same massive 8K vistivision sensor as
dsmc2 but it's a new body style and it's
a new cam a new computer inside and
that's what makes a DSM C3 I think dsmc
stands for digital Stills and motion
camera I believe
um but either way you could sort of look
at this as a Next Generation versus this
one but either way it's the same huge
sensor
everything else is different now there
are some advantages to a new camera body
but with the same sensor for one you get
a very familiar image quality but now
there's a new computer inside so you can
get slightly better noise reduction out
of the same sensor and then of course
faster processing from a better computer
allows for higher frame rates so 8K at
120 frames per second full frame like I
mentioned which is ridiculous but the
new body is pretty nice to look at too
so it's like a sort of bigger version of
the Komodo it's this boxy cubish shape
and almost everything here is built in
instead of being attachable with
optional modules so there's a Canon RF
Mount at the front that supports phase
attack autofocus and even added this
ring lock which is pretty nice plus the
red record button in the corner and some
pinhole mics and then around the sides
there's a lot of ventilation so up top
there's a huge exhaust fan and on both
sides you've got a lot of airflow this
is not a water resistant camera at all
but pretty similar to some other Cinema
cameras this one's just smaller now on
the left side there's a single CF
Express type B slot with this nice high
quality metal spring-loaded door might
be the nicest card door I've ever seen
and then on the right side there is a
two and a half inch matte display it's
not a touch screen but it's surrounded
by buttons for camera control then
around the back that's where all the
business happens there's your Wi-Fi
antenna for connecting straight to your
phone or you've got a USB type-c port if
you want to go straight into an iPad or
something like that two SDI ports a
headphone jack power time code and even
one of the weirdest audio ports I've
ever seen five pin Audio Plus can't
forget about this new micro v-lock
battery mount on the left and then
around the corner is the record button
and a speaker for Scratch audio playback
and the power switch and you also may
have noticed an actual ton of mounting
points they're all over this thing the
top up the front the back the sides even
these handles which are all metal also
have a bunch of quarter twenties a bunch
of mounting points on them so it's very
uh function over form it's just a lot of
things you can mount onto the side of
this including lights mics all kinds of
stuff like that but the number one thing
you notice is how dense it is this is a
very dense camera even without a lens or
a battery or monitor or anything it's
four pounds which doesn't sound like
much butting your hand that's that's a
lot and then you add all this stuff and
it's definitely heavier so this is a
dense little brick of a camera so a
couple thoughts on it one uh I really
like the white and black accent type of
Design This is the Stormtrooper one so
it's one of the earliest that they make
it's a limited edition
but also as someone who shoots mostly
dark and reflective surfaces like
gadgets and screens uh a white camera
not the best idea it tends to show up in
Reflections a lot but that's on me
that's on me but then two I think how
much I love this camera will end up
coming down to
what type of accessories I can get for
it what type of stuff comes out for it
because dsmc2 like I said you just got
the brain and then you got to choose
every single perfect accessory I love
this setup here with the side handle
with the record button the top handle I
used all the time this monitors very
bright swivels all the way around I
built this up to be perfect exactly how
I want it mostly with red accessories I
got a gdu battery but everything else is
like made by Red
and that ecosystem doesn't exist for
this camera yet so it's just a couple of
the things that come with the the
package for it
and I'm actually impressed by how many
different like Partnerships they've made
for it they actually partnered with core
for these batteries and they partnered
with Angel bird for the card and the
card reader and they partnered with
small HD for an official monitor that's
coming out later this year I'm hoping
that means other third-party stuff will
start to get added and built by other
manufacturers too just because I don't
know these handles it's there's no easy
way to hold this camera as a box I'm
like this back record button is not easy
to hit all the time so it's not really
meant for one person shooting the way
this was
um really hoping for a better set of
handles and definitely looking forward
to seeing what other accessories can
make this really good but then the other
I guess obvious downside is something
like this where everything is built in
versus the previous version which is the
modular setup is you only get what red
gives you which is built in or you'll
have to adapt so like there's no uh
redundant media recording like many have
noted in other Redcat cameras it's just
the one card at a time there's no HDMI
out you might have noticed in this
camera there's no XLR for audio there's
that one weird audio port now I couldn't
help but notice at the bottom of Red's
site they have this like diagram looking
thing it's in plain sight like you could
easily miss it if you didn't know what
you're looking for but it just says V
Raptor XL coming in 2022 and then some
diagrams of this larger looking dsmc3
camera this one looks like it has way
more i o including more audio so maybe
that bigger one ends up being the one
that works better in certain workflows
or you don't want to have to adapt as
much but the main headliner of V Raptor
in this new dsmc3 computer is in the
title of this video
the new high frame rate 8K at 120 frames
per second full frame and if you know
anything about RED cameras that also
means you can crop down to a smaller
part of the sensor and shoot even higher
frame rates 600 frames per second at 2K
1080p
are you serious so full frame 8K raw at
120 frames per second as you can imagine
takes a lot of data and a lot of
computing power so you'll need these
fast cards to be able to write fast
enough to shoot like that and if you
start shooting at those lower
resolutions like I said it does crop in
on the sensor so you are zoomed in quite
a bit but that will unlock even higher
frame rates as high as 600 frames per
second which is absolutely nuts now as
someone who mostly shoots videos of
things sitting still
I might not use that a ton personally
but the one thing that immediately came
to mind was actually showing the real
difference between 120 hertz and 60
hertz in a 30 FPS video so that should
be I guess theoretically twice as
obvious as before since dsmc2 maxed out
at 8K at a mere 60 FPS so you know what
we're going to do we're going to dive
right off into the deep end and shoot
the iPhone 13 Pro review
on the V Raptor unless something goes
horribly wrong you can expect that
entire video to be all image quality
shot from that camera all the a-roll all
the b-roll the intro as well which is
pretty exciting
wish us luck and I don't even have that
many RF lenses so I'll be actually
adapting to EF to continue to use my
favorites I only have this one 660 gig
memory card which sounds like a lot but
like I said shooting 8K raw I promise
you this fills up pretty quick but let's
see if we give it a shot let's see how
it goes and we'll we'll really try some
stuff like I said like we never really
shoot much High frame rate but we'll do
that I would absolutely avoid at all
costs shooting over about 800 to 1000
ISO on these previous RED cameras same
sensor better computer better noise
reduction maybe we can get away with
higher ISO on this camera we'll try some
of that too we'll see if the battery
life is any different it's the same
physical capacity battery so that should
be fun to see all of that will be
reported back and if you haven't already
subscribed to the studio YouTube channel
that's where we'll be reporting also a
lot of these like real-time findings as
we shoot with it see what our
experiences are shooting V Raptor so
definitely go subscribe to the studio if
you haven't already and that's pretty
much it for my first impression again
super dense really interesting camera to
shoot with can't wait for better handles
and better accessories but
V Raptor also we don't know what the V
stands for I don't think do we what do
you what do you think the v stands for
you can make up whatever you want
basically uh but that's basically it if
you had a camera like this what would
you shoot with this at 8K 120 let me
know in the comments either way until
the next one thanks for watching see you
guys in 8k in the next video
face
[Music]